as you welcome
[Applause]
I get you yeah oh are we on oh no here
we are okay so uh you've all was it more
difficult to write a book for children
than for adults uh yes much more
difficult really when you write for
adults and you don't know something you
can use a lot of very difficult words
and they think they don't get you but
with kids it doesn't work you have to
really know what you're saying really
otherwise they don't take it isn't that
interesting I always thought you could
fool kids because they're stupid
foreign
they don't they haven't heard all the
stories that we believe ah so they ask
more difficult questions okay uh Jillian
mortgage rates Rose above seven percent
in the US this week what do you make of
the fed's monetary policy boy wow okay I
am the financial times
the boring hour where everyone goes oh
um okay basically the FED is in a rock
and a hard place and that inflation has
been rising if it doesn't act it could
get a lot worse but if acts too quickly
then it's going to end up essentially we
can have a recession I mean well I see
we're already losing a lot of money in
the market right yeah probably yes
unfortunately and how long will it last
will it be bad or a lot depends what
happens yeah things like you know reward
Ukraine yeah elsewhere China China's
slowing down that's pretty significant
for the global economy
um it's not looking great yeah one
reason we need comedy shows the traffic
is all right and also traffic is always
later
I'm not saying I'm rooting for one I'm
just saying
they gotta have you gotta lead them it's
like when you're in Vegas you know you
get insurance on a hand
[Laughter]
Quentin you wrote a novelization of Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood last year you
just published your first film analysis
book what do you plan on writing next or
I I guess another question what this
might be is this you know writing is it
how does it compare I would want to know
to like filmmaking it can't give you the
kind of rush you have but it's probably
not as exhausting
well it's actually well
it's interesting especially like in
doing some well okay
it's interesting because one of the
things that is just really gratifying
about writing a book or something is the
idea that I would really invest into
writing these scripts that I would do
and I put my whole hardened Soul into
them and they were like these Mount
Everest that was climbing and this one
is Kilimanjaro and the next one is Fuji
you know and so I'm just these you know
just going all out there then I would
invest all this time and all this energy
and then I'm finished with the script
well now I have to go and make it you
know and if I'm happy with the script
then I was mine to mess up uh in the in
the directing of it the thing that's
really kind of cool about writing a book
is like you put all your time and energy
into it and then when the book is done
you're done I don't have to go and spend
nine months uh you know go hang out and
making the movie and all that stuff and
then like spending another you know four
or six months uh selling it all around
the world I still kind of do that a
little bit but you know trying to say
it's actually uh um because usually when
I would finish a screenplay I would sort
of like I would question should I just
publish the screenplay because I've just
put everything I have into it and no one
is ever going to read it other than the
actors who are doing the movie
I I know that Spielberg had said at one
point that making the movie was kind of
drudgery for him because he'd already
made it in his head okay I'm not going
as far as that because I'm sorry making
a movie is like the funnest thing right
if you're in a position to make movies
it's a and you can kind of do a lot with
what you would like to do I mean God
there's just that's hardly a better job
than that I mean it's just really great
and if you pretty girls
violence and if you're able to just like
you know uh you know I've been in a
really lucky position I can just conjure
up little interesting stories that I
want to tell and uh a cast of characters
I get to the best it's up to you get to
choose from the best actors it's
charismatic people hang out with them
slow [ __ ] up yeah
it's a blast you know my sets are known
my sets are known for being one of the
funnest sets in Hollywood I mean you
know the people in iatse want to work on
a Quentin movie all right because
they're going to have a ball
so you'd be hurting a lot of people if
you quit anyway
will future Generations be appalled by
some of the current decision of course
current decisions are actually we're
making as a society what are some things
we do today that are generally accepted
but we'll look bad in the future well
the animal well you're the guy to answer
that
act like I'm raping Ned Beatty in the
woods
but animals I would say eating animals
raising onions
even if we still eat them there's no
need to torture them while they're alive
I mean even California now is good for
California has passed a law the Supreme
Court is hearing arguments about it
whether it can stand in other states but
we passed a law that said you have to
you know we're not stop selling bacon
but you have to raise the pigs humanely
yeah I mean they're smart sensitive
animals yeah I'll be smarter than kids
no
you can go and go and adopt a pig but
what else what do you think else in a
hundred years I mean I'm off the top of
my head beauty pageants I think is
probably gonna go
well that's cutting edge of you they've
been saying that for 40 years
antibiotic resistance the fact that we
use so many antibiotics that you know
Society is becoming or listened to it
and we could have not so much a pandemic
but another big medical disaster from
that that's a slightly different
category but yes that's something that's
of great worry I mean we we are heading
toward the post-antibiotic age I always
say I never want to take an antibiotic
but boy am I glad they exist because
when you need it I mean people would be
dying of a splinter again I mean that's
that's certainly possible so but
anything that we we are doing that we
are choosing to do you know choosing
strong men dictators to build leaders I
mean I hope that in the in 100 years
people would look back at it and think
this was as as lunatic as we look back
at some of the political systems back in
in history right I don't know monarchs
in the grace of God ruling the country
or something like that England still has
a monarch but but she doesn't rule he
okay
yeah
I think one of the dumbest things been
taking democracy for granted it's
actually a point about 15 of kids voting
and that is you know and treating
politics other reality TV show that's
what you expect from it you know there
is reality DB what's the Kardashians
don't expect your politicians to act
like them and then vote for ones who do
and maybe out of that that you know the
expectation for authenticity I mean we
don't need authentic leaders we need
responsible leaders authenticity
you know
saying the first thing that comes to
your mind or tweeting it it's good in
therapy right but
right you need to build a wall between
your mind and your mouth right and be
very careful about what you let through
them and yet some politician love walls
very much in all kinds of places except
between their mind and their mind but
you can't Outlaw that because you can't
Outlaw I mean in terms of what we what
we tolerate what we expect well we can
expect you have to tolerate that's what
Free Speech means if that's you have to
tolerate things there's lots of things I
don't want to tolerate in the world but
I have to tolerate I wish I could talk
to you all night but I have to tolerate
closing the show and I must say you know
with all my cynicism
go vote do it anyway it just might help
all right we'll see you next week